[Music]
heyo everybody I am back with another
cooking video and today we are gonna be
making one of my favorites my mom used
to make this for me when I was sick when
I wasn't sick it's one of those you make
it on a Sunday night you have enough
leftovers to last you well into the week
and this is a classic home kind of food
home food for Chinese families and this
is kanji or Joel called porridge Chinese
porridge it's a rice based GU actually
it's really really flavorful it's very
high in nutrients I would say just like
chicken noodle soup the base of this is
chicken broth there's a couple secrets
to this dish that I think makes it pop
and have its secrets I want to share
with you that I've learned from my mom
she makes the best chicken congee and I
don't think I have mastered this dish
the way she has yet there's there's
nothing like going home and having her
make it for me
but I'll try my best to replicate the
recipe and I'm here to share it with you
guys
so first up you're gonna start with a
whole chicken so what I can do is I chop
it up into pieces and we're gonna take
this chicken and place it into a
stockpot with about three liters of
water now this dish takes a while to
make about three hours two hours for the
chicken broth and then another hour for
the actual congee part so once you have
the chicken in the water bring it to a
boil and then once it's up to a boil you
want to let it simmer for two hours now
you can ramp this up with some extra
flavors like you can throw some green
onions in to the broth or some ginger
slices into the broth and I'll give it
some extra layers of flavor if you like
for me the simpler the better for this
dish I don't want to overwhelm it with
too much flavors I like how simple it is
now while your chicken broth is
simmering there's gonna be a lot of that
gunk that floats to the top the
impurities as they call it now what
you're gonna want to do is skim out all
the impurities and all the fat that's
floating to the top as it simmers if you
don't you're gonna have a very oily joke
which is not that fun to eat and also
scooping out the impurities gives the
joke cleaner presence
traditionally joke is done with white
rice and you know you want your job to
be very very clean looking but the
chicken broth if you don't clear out the
impurities as they float to the top
it'll definitely give it a much dirtier
look so if you care about presentation
which I feel like this day and age
thanks to Instagram and YouTube and all
a bunch of social media presentation is
very key for food now okay so now while
you're making this chicken broth while
it's simmering we're gonna want to get
started on the rice and the chicken meat
both these things we're gonna marinate
separately now with the rice you're
thinking wait hold on marinating rice
yes there's a way to flavor this rice
and this is definitely the secret and
the big secret to marinating the rice
here is using century egg aka
thousand-year-old egg aka
hundred-year-old egg it's that black
preserved egg that most people find very
unappetizing looks terrible smells
terrible and in fact it's it's you know
taste wise it's also an acquired taste
if you're eating it hold so what you're
gonna do with the rice is take a
separate pot now we're gonna put about
two-thirds cup of rice into this and
make sure we wash the rice and then from
there we're gonna take the century egg
we're gonna peel it and drop the whole
egg into the pot of rice the next part
can be the fun part we're gonna mush the
egg into the rice and this is the big
secret to making the best congee in the
world with the preserved egg there is a
lot of I actually don't even know what
kind of crisp chemicals that are in
there it definitely smells like ammonia
or something I don't know whatever is in
this preserved egg when mushed into the
rice and marinated into the rice it
brings out the best rice flavor ever and
as you marinate as you squeeze it into
the rice grain so there's a reaction in
the rice the rice starts to puff up a
little bit so whatever chemical reaction
is happening in this rice with the
preserved egg it adds so much flavor to
the congee and then we're gonna let that
sit for about 30 minutes to an hour and
let the flavors meld together and get
that rice nice and marinated
and also we're gonna need to marinate
the chicken now you can choose between a
white meat or dark meat thighs or
breasts personally I like to do dark
meat because I find dark meat a lot more
flavorful it's a different kind of
texture that white meat yes and but I do
think darkman has a lot more flavor so I
personally choose dark meat but if
you're on a health-conscious thing or
you just like the texture of white meat
by all means use white meat I've gotten
four thighs I'm gonna cut it up into
little slices of chicken pieces I like
to also get rid of as much of the fat as
possible so it's a leaner dish and now
once you have it all added to a bowl
we're gonna add two tablespoons of soy
sauce one teaspoon of white pepper 1
tablespoon of rice wine and one teaspoon
of sesame oil and add a pinch of salt as
well optionally you can also add in
diced ginger or diced garlic to your
marinade but like I said I like to keep
mine really really simple so now once
you have all this stuff added in go
ahead and do the same process we're
gonna take our hands and we're gonna
squeeze the crap out of the chicken
pieces and get the marinade and the
flavors worked in together
so once the marinade has worked in go
ahead and let the chicken sit for about
an hour and at this point we've done
most of the work already it's a super
simple recipe
all right so fast forward we are now
ready to combine all the ingredients
together and we are going to toast the
rice a little bit and after about a
minute or two we're gonna pour in our
chicken broth now an easy way to pour in
the chicken broth is I take out all the
chicken pieces the the bones take it all
out and I just so you can have a clean
pore of your chicken broth homemade
chicken broth now this is the biggest
difference between good congee and and
just kind of generic congee is you have
to make your own chicken broth making
your own chicken broth is also is
another way of really making
dish shine and pop so you pour all the
chicken broth into the rice and give it
a stir make sure none of the rice pieces
stick at the bottom because that's one
thing about making drug is you have to
keep it moving sometimes to prevent the
bottom from burning go ahead and close
the lid and we're gonna bring this to a
boil and once it's at a boil we're gonna
let it simmer for a full hour and just
let that rice cook and soften we want to
get it to that goopy texture like
oatmeal as we're nearing the end of the
hour I like to add in a full tablespoon
of salt to the congee all right so well
after our full hour of cooking go ahead
and turn off the stove and this part is
another trick that I have is to cook the
marinated chicken in the residual heat
inside that big pot of congee so this is
my technique this is not something you
have to do you can definitely if you
feel more comfortable keep it in the
stove on with the fire and putting in
the chicken meat and having that chicken
cook with full full summer mode by all
means definitely go ahead and do that
but if you want it cooked just right not
overcook chicken and it's tender and
flavorful and it keeps its own juices
you want to let that chicken cook in the
residual heat tell you it's gonna be the
juiciest most tender chicken they'll
have in congee otherwise if when it
boils in it to me the chicken gets kind
of rough I'm not a big fan of rough
chicken meat so during this 15 minutes
of residual heat cooking of the chicken
I like to bring out some green onions
some ginger and what I like to do is to
dice the green onions and shred the
ginger and this will act as both our
garnish and
as a nice fresh aromatic to our dough
let's go ahead and plate our kanji in a
bowl and what you are looking for and
what you want to relish is this oatmeal
texture definitely looks like home food
it's not meant to look amazing
Instagram ready or anything but it is so
good trust me if it's raining if it's
cold outside congee is my go-to like
comfort food so once you have it in a
bowl I like to top it off with the
ginger and the green onions and wallah
that is mom's congee alright guys I hope
you guys liked this video it's one of my
favorite home dishes to make and I hope
you guys give it a try especially if
you're under the weather or it's cold
outside this is one of the best dishes
this is the Chinese chicken noodle soup
so full of flavor full of good stuff for
your health so like always thanks for
watching make sure to comment down below
what you'd like to see me make next and
don't forget to subscribe thanks
[Music]
[Music]